[MUSIC PLAYING]
NANCY KANWISHER: In a very deep
sense, the brain is who we are.
And so by looking at
what it's made up of,
what it's pieces are and
what each piece does,
I think that's
starting to sketch
for us a picture of the mind.
SARAH HANSEN: Today
on Chalk Radio,
we're exploring our most
critical biological asset,
our brain.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen.
My guest this week
is a scientist
and MIT Professor who studies
the architecture of the brain.
NANCY KANWISHER:
I'm Nancy Kanwisher,
and I'm an investigator in the
McGovern Institute for Brain
Research and a member of
the Department of Brain
and Cognitive Sciences.
And I study the human brain
and how it's organized
at a very macro scale level.
I'm interested in big parts
of the brain and what they do.
SARAH HANSEN: In addition
to being an investigator,
Nancy Kanwisher is
a founding member
of the McGovern
Institute, which is
a community of neuroscientists
who are working
to better understand the brain.
I was curious how Nancy got
into her field of research
and the advancements that
have developed over the years
since she's been working in it.
NANCY KANWISHER: When I
started in cognitive psychology
the methods we had available
were pretty rudimentary.
I measured reaction
time and accuracy
when people did simple
tasks looking at pictures
and understanding sentences.
And from that very
sparse low-tech data
of people's responses,
behavioral responses
in different tasks, we tried
to infer the algorithms running
in their heads.
And that's kind of like trying
to figure out how a car works
just by driving it around.
And you could
discover some stuff.
You could probably figure
out that there's something
like gearshifts just by
studying its behavior.
You could figure out a bunch
of things about car engines
just by driving them around.
I mean, you could figure
out even more once you study
the different ways
that cars break down,
like OK, sometimes
they have this problem
and sometimes they
have that problem,
and then from that
you could infer,
even if you didn't
know anything before,
what the different pieces
of a car engine might do.
So for a long time,
that's what our field had,
is basically driving brains
around and studying what
happens when they break down.
But then more recently
these amazing methods
came along that enabled
us to look inside.
And so in my first
year in graduate school
the first non-invasive study
of function in the human brain
was published on the
cover of Science.
And here was this
unbelievably blurry picture,
but nevertheless a
picture of activity
in the back of the head
where visual cortex resides.
And that picture
just blew my mind.
And I wrote to every brain
imaging lab in the world,
there were only
about 5 back then,
and I said I have these
ideas for experiments,
and I sent them my
proposals, and crickets.
And so I kept at it,
and it was, literally,
10 years before I got to do
a brain imaging experiment.
Spending a lot of
that time beating
on the doors trying to get
access to the machines,
but the machines were
big and expensive.
They were controlled mostly by
MDs, who to be blunt about it,
didn't really know what
psychological questions to ask
because that's not their field.
We psychologists are the
ones with the questions.
We were the ones who
were studying minds
and who knew what to
look for in brains.
But we psychologists didn't get
to use the big fancy machines
for another decade.
And then it's been really
quite a party since then.
SARAH HANSEN: Nancy
explained to me
that our most basic
understanding of the brain
has been known for a long period
of time, 100 years or more.
And interestingly, some of the
most astounding discoveries
have come not from
studying the healthy brain
but by studying damaged ones.
More recently, with
new technologies
such as functional MRI, which
is a specific type of MRI that
scans for metabolic
function in the brain,
we've been able to expand and
grow our knowledge in ways that
provide information that's far
more specific than we've ever
had before.
NANCY KANWISHER:
For a couple years
we've had the idea that
regions in the left side
of the lateral, temporal,
and frontal lobes
are involved in
processing language.
And we've known
that because people
who have damage to those regions
sometimes lose their language
abilities.
And similarly, we
knew that somewhere
in the back of the right
hemisphere near the bottom
there was some kind
of function that was
involved in face recognition.
And again, we knew that
from the small number
of people who had damage
to that part of the brain
and lost their ability
to recognize faces,
sometimes without losing their
ability to recognize objects,
or words, or scenes, and
that was strongly suggestive,
that, hey, maybe there's
a special bit of the brain
for face recognition.
That kind of stuff has
been known for a long time,
but that was it, right?
And then functional
MRI came along
and now we have dozens
of regions of cortex
where we have a pretty
good idea of what
each of those little
patches of cortex does.
And many of those regions do
a very, very specific things
like just thinking about what
other people are thinking,
or just understanding language,
or just face recognition.
SARAH HANSEN:
Facial recognition.
That's a topic that gets
talked about a lot at my house,
mostly because my spouse
seems to struggle with it.
I was curious if
this was typical.
NANCY KANWISHER: Never
mind brain damage.
Take perfectly normal people.
You test a hundred of them
on their face recognition
abilities and what you find
is that those abilities
are widely varying.
And some people are just
awful, like the bottom two
people in your group of
100, those bottom two people
routinely fail to
recognize family members.
I mean, that's really bad.
And the top 2% of people are
so good that they routinely
hide it from others
because other people
would find it creepy.
SARAH HANSEN: So I
live with someone who
on a scale of 1 to
10 probably a three.
I would say I'm about a six.
And where would
you put yourself?
NANCY KANWISHER: Oh, I'm
about a two or a three.
I'm really bad.
I have to ask my partner
when we're watching a movie,
is that the protagonist?
Is that the other one?
Oh, I'm bad.
Yeah.
SARAH HANSEN: Wow.
While each individual
part of the brain
is uniquely important, one
big takeaway Nancy explained
is that every mental function
requires many brain regions.
And understanding that is
key to understanding how
the brain operates as a whole.
NANCY KANWISHER: Nothing lives
in just one piece of the brain.
So even when I carry on about
how some parts of the brain
do very specific
things, that doesn't
mean that they do that
very specific thing alone.
Every mental function requires
many different brain regions.
The part that's involved
in face recognition
could not do its task
without getting input
from primary visual cortex and
other basic visual regions.
And there would be no
use of face recognition
if it didn't send
its information
to other parts of the
brain that know things
like your Rolodex of people.
You have that
someplace in the brain.
It's not very well
understood, but someplace you
know all the facts you know
about the people you know.
And so each of
those brain regions
acts in concert with lots
of other brain regions.
SARAH HANSEN: It's one thing to
understand how the brain works
in the abstract, but in her
course, 9.13 The Human Brain,
Nancy connects neuroscience with
something much more personal.
She begins the semester with
a story, a personal anecdote
she uses to paint a picture
of all the various topics she
seeks to introduce in her class.
NANCY KANWISHER: It's
widely recognized
that people like stories and
people resonate to stories.
There's a whole developing
meme and science
communication about how you're
supposed to tell stories.
And for a long time
it's, like, yeah,
I know I supposed
to tell a story,
but I just have my
lectures and I don't know--
I don't know what
story to tell or I--
and then I realized oh my
god, I do have a story.
And I was psyched to
realize that, actually,
that story echoes,
to an eerie degree,
all of the themes of the course.
And it's the story
of a friend of mine
who had a brain tumor, which was
revealed very dramatically when
he collapsed on the floor
at my house unconscious.
Horrifying, terrifying, but
it pulls people in right away.
He's fine now, to cut to
the chase, totally fine,
but in between, there was quite
a scary and fascinating set
of developments in which
he had a benign tumor that
was pressing against
a region of his brain,
that my lab had
studied, that's involved
in knowing where you are.
And I knew this guy pretty
well, and so I had actually
been noticing for
a few years that he
seemed to have lost his
ability to navigate around
in the world.
And it scared me and worried
me, but I just didn't even
make myself think about it.
And so I should have known
what was up with this guy.
I had all the data
in front of me
and I somehow didn't, until
he collapsed on the floor
and it kind of
all came together.
And I thought, oh my god,
what's going on with his brain?
And further, eerily, we
had actually scanned him
in one of the standard
experiments in my lab
many years before, and
so when he called me,
after he collapsed, and he
recovered a minute or two later
and spent the day in
the ER while they're
trying to figure out what
was happening with him,
and all day long the
ER docs are saying,
oh, this is a heart
thing, this is
whatever, we'll figure it out.
And after test, after
test, after test,
that night he calls me and he
says, get over here right now.
They found something
in my brain.
So I was just horrified.
And as I'm driving
over to the ER,
I called one of my
lab techs and I said,
hey, we scanned
this guy years ago.
See if you can dig
around in the files
and find the anatomical
scans we would have made
when we did that brain study.
And so by the time I
got there, the MRI tech
did something they're
probably not supposed to do,
but they showed him and
me pictures of his brain
with this huge thing,
the size of a lime,
right in the middle
of his brain.
It was just horrifying.
And then I was able
to look at the images
that my lab had collected
quite a few years before.
And we could see it,
even many years before.
It was much smaller,
but clearly visible.
And that was very
important, clinically,
because it showed that this
was a very slow growing tumor.
And that was good news.
And very diagnostic about
what kind of tumor it was.
SARAH HANSEN: As scary
as this experience
was, not just for Nancy,
but also for her friend,
it led to some
important discoveries.
Nancy was able to
test and receive
results in real time about how
her friend's navigation ability
was impacted by the tumor.
Because of this, she was able
to confirm her own research
about how his ability to
navigate the world around him
was impacted by the
tumor pressing down
on a specific
region of his brain.
NANCY KANWISHER: In
the whole process
of watching my friend
go through this,
I tested him on
a bunch of tasks.
He was totally game.
It's like try drawing a
floor plan of your apartment,
and he draws this total mess.
I mean, it just--
I've been in his apartment.
I know what the floor plan is.
And what he drew had just
no relation whatsoever.
And then I said, OK,
try drawing a floor plan
of the upstairs of my house.
We were in the downstairs
of my house right then.
Couldn't do it.
And then I thought,
well, maybe it's
just complex multi-part
images, things
that are hard to reconstruct.
So I said, OK, try drawing
a sketch of a bicycle.
So he draws a bicycle.
It was not beautiful, but
it was clearly recognizable.
It had all the right parts
in the right positions.
And that's a very
low tech simple
example of one of the
main methods in my field,
is studying people
with brain damage
and trying to analyze exactly
what is it that's messed up
and what is it that's preserved.
And that shows you
this implausible split.
Why would you be
able to remember
the visual appearance of places
but not the visual appearance
of objects?
But that's exactly what,
actually, my own research
predicted.
SARAH HANSEN: I asked Nancy
how her students respond
to hearing this story.
She told me that students
respond by asking questions.
This idea of investigating,
questioning, and really holding
on to curiosity
is exactly what's
at the heart of
Nancy's teaching.
NANCY KANWISHER: They proceed
to ask all the questions that
are the basic
questions that we're
going to explore in the course.
I just tell them the story
and then they say OK,
did it get better?
How long did you know?
What other symptoms did he have?
Did he have this
particular other thing?
Did it affect other
things besides scenes?
How would you study
it besides MRI?
Would you-- on and on and on.
But it's like every
single question they ask,
these are just the
questions we ask
in my field, which is one of the
things I love about this field,
is that it's not like
quantum mechanics.
You don't need to study for
years and years and years
before you even have
the mental space where
you can frame the questions.
All of the questions
of interest in my field
are questions that any
normal person can ask
with no background whatsoever.
That's the cool thing about
the brain, is we have one
and we get to use it and we
get to watch it in action.
And we have already been
wondering all these questions,
whether we realize it or not.
I mean, one of my favorite
things to point out
is that lots of
questions that people
have been wondering about
anyway, like how solid
is human knowledge.
We think we know this stuff.
Do we really know it?
Are we fooling ourselves?
Those are questions
that can be asked
in lots of different ways, but
one of the ways of asking them
is to look at brain development
and where the structure
of the brain comes from.
The kinds of questions that
you can ask and sometimes
even answer in my field are
questions that lots of people
wonder about.
SARAH HANSEN: This was a
particularly powerful part
of the conversation for me.
The idea that this kind
of study is accessible,
that's not something
you typically
infer when you hear
cognitive neuroscience.
Nancy Kanwisher
wants to change that.
Part of her mission is
to allow everyone access
to the knowledge
generated by the field.
NANCY KANWISHER: The
public pays for the science
we do in the lab,
and so I think it's
a moral obligation of
scientists to give back.
And I think I'm in the lucky
position that the stuff I do
is easily shareable with people.
And so I think it would be
just not OK not to share it.
And so I try to share
it whenever I can.
But it's also fun.
It's really fun to get
an idea across and see
somebody resonate to it.
So I think an
educational goal that I
don't think I've quite
figured out how to do
but that I aspire towards
is to give people a push
and encourage them to find
a few things because that
will teach them that they can
then go find more on their own.
I would love it if
some of my research
would actually
help people, but it
would be a lie if I told
you that that's why I do it
or that we have already been
able to help a lot of people.
That's just not true.
The real thing that
motivates me is I
just think it's the grandest
scientific quest of all time
to understand the human mind.
And looking at a brain is
a great way to do that.
So that's really
what I'm in it for,
is just the pure fascination
of understanding our own minds.
To me, it's like all
about sharing things
that I think are cool
because, actually, my teaching
goal is to blow people's minds.
SARAH HANSEN: Blowing people's
minds by teaching about them.
It's one of the
things that makes
Nancy's course so compelling.
And by the way, I
asked Nancy if there
were insights about
teaching that she
wished our listeners
would share with her.
NANCY KANWISHER: Well, there
are all kinds of topics
that I haven't figured out how
to lecture on, that I just have
a blind spot on, like memory.
This is a big part of the field.
There's really
beautiful work on it.
Lots of people study it.
But I have just a
hard time motivating
what the big questions are,
and so I don't actually
lecture on memory.
And I'm really
embarrassed about that,
but I just haven't
figured out how
to give a good lecture on it.
That's one.
Emotions.
I've never figured out how
to lecture about emotions.
And of course, everybody
cares about them
and they're really
important and there
are neural stories to be told
and experiments to read about.
And I am just not very
good on that topic.
SARAH HANSEN: If you
have insights to share,
please get in touch with us
at the link in our show notes.
And when you do,
you'll be joining Nancy
in making cognitive neuroscience
more accessible to all of us.
If you're interested in learning
from her open and free teaching
materials or remixing
them in your own teaching,
you can find them on our
MIT OpenCourseWare website.
Additionally, you
can find Nancy's work
at the McGovern Institute by
visiting McGovern.mit.edu.
Thank you so much for listening.
Until next time, signing off
from Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
Chalk Radio's producers
include myself, Brett Paci
and Dave Lashansky.
Scriptwriting assistance
from Nidhi Shastry.
Show notes for this episode
were written by Peter Chipman.
The 9.13 OCW course site was
built by Shiba Nemat-Nasser.
We're funded by MIT Open
Learning and supporters
like you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]